okay so my talk is about open source
contributions in iron Finance they're
working on the slides I can at least
talk to you before it gets started
before they put everything up so really
was just to introduce people to open
open open source work because it's my
introduction to open source and so
basically I was gonna first start with
just introducing myself so hi I'm Sami
AX I'm on a couple of different
initiatives related to our I'm an
analyst by day and a lot of this talk
will not actually all of this talk will
not represent any of my employers
opinions only my own I always have to
caveat that and I'm on the I helped
organize the New York late hour lady's
chapter as well as I'm also on the
committee for are in finance why I
wanted to talk about open source
contributions in in our finance and
basically about about a year ago when I
started when I started working with our
ladies I was introduced to the world of
open source contributions and so it
really kind of opened my eyes and I saw
people like I robbed and all these other
are ladies doing these amazing things
and I was like wow I do this I do some
of this stuff but I don't know so it was
a little scary and I hope I just put my
contact info up there so please reach
out even if you wanted to criticize my
talk okay so a contribution to open
source initially when I thought about it
it was terrifying I really thought that
everyone that's out there that's
contributing is probably an expert and I
was like oh everyone has to be like
Hadleys level to contribute so I was
kind of a little lost where to begin so
of course I thought of the one thing
that I wanted to do which was do real
estate investing I live in New York we
have very very small spaces where we
live and so basically I always am on the
lookout for a bigger and better closet
okay so no and I'll tell you have it
started a little bit so two of my
colleagues at work will show pictures of
at the end actually are really into this
one of them invest a lot and so so he
kind of got me started and showed me the
data I got me very excited so anyway so
the first data source that I'm gonna
present is on the survey data that's
done the American Community Survey which
is actually done every year but it's but
the for this analysis I'm using the five
door data from 2012 to 2016 so that's
basically from December
first I or January 1st 2012 to December
31st 2016 and um it told me because
every year they do it only for
populations greater than 3.5 million the
surveys done for that no it's done for
population greater than 65 thousand but
3.5 million people are surveyed so
generally just just to get more thorough
data I chose to look at the 5-year set
for now it includes pretty much a lot of
cool stuff like social data housing data
economic data and demographic statistics
okay so how did I get this an arm I said
there I learned that there are 22
packages that really deal with census
data talk about like over contribution
in the open source space and the one
cool one that I started working with
because I saw Julia still be working
with it was the tiny census package she
even has a tutorial on it which like
just made my life thousand times easier
I have the link in the slides ok and the
other set of data that you really want
to get your hands on if you can if you
want to really play with real estate
would be MLS data so what is MLS data so
it's actually lists individual listings
but they're all done at the local level
and there's no like aggregated database
that collect all this information allows
you to access it so there are no I think
there are some aggregated services I
think like Zillow etc are like they have
access to some of the zip codes but not
everything there's other people the
audience that are far more knowledgeable
about this please come up and explain
more to me and I just couldn't find a
whole lot of any public or free api's we
actually eventually ended up going down
a subscription and that's how we built a
lot of the stuff that I build today and
basically there's no standardization as
in the the data is incredibly dirty so
when I first started mapping things it
was mapping it to the wrong areas and
I'll give you examples when I show you
stuff and so on and a lot of the
analysis that I'm gonna be doing today
is all based on zip code analysis so the
census data if you're familiar with it
at all is all in the state and county
level so there's some like there are
there are areas a lot of people when
they do census data is like it's on the
state and county level but there isn't a
way to pull in some zip code level
information so it's interesting to see
how that can match up and really show
you some trends ok how did I get the
cenar I had to purchase it okay so the
packages I use today are leaflet for
visualization various
I can't I'm not gonna are good al good I
can't pronounce package name so you're
gonna have to forgive me and read them
so for finance I use the fin Cal package
if any of you have liked the calculator
they give you for like the CFA exams
really put in the mortgage bond
something like that okay and the data
science obviously the tidy verse and
deep liar
so yeah since I live in New York and I
told you about my constant need for
space in New York I decided to look at
New York uh-huh so so let me tell you
what I first did so as I said the MLS
data and the census data is the MLS data
is incredibly incredibly dirty so I had
to do a lot of cleanup and then I merged
all of it so I wanted to show you at a
snapshot for how like this is this is
not at all incredibly detailed I would
do a lot more now that I know how to do
this so but even this information is
quite a lot so you have like days on
market you have you have it at the
postal code level you have square feet
you have the Year build I wish I had
done this before moving into my current
place you have like the prime and then I
calculated the annualized income the
price to rent ratio the annualized
expenditure etc which I'll show you
graphs of but so it has a lot of
information that we can use this okay so
the first thing that you do right when
you get this data say you're like okay I
just want to get a flavor for what's
happening right so you look at median
prices because if you think about it or
and essentially any area right if you're
looking at the zip code level there are
obviously some houses that are far more
expensive and there are some houses that
are far cheaper right just because of
many different factors so I figured I
thought in this case since I was just
doing an initial glance I would start
looking at medians so so I used the
leaflet package to develop the first
round of median prices for every
neighborhood in New York City so this is
what this came out so I also discovered
an interesting problem with this so in
my art studio window this actually
rendered and showed everything in the
right place
but I think here it does not so that's
very upsetting but it but the point of
this graph actually that are the map
actually is quite interesting so if you
look these are the five boroughs of New
York and this is broken out by
percentile so if you look here all the
yellow is essentially where the most
expensive places are right which is
which is not rendering
very prettily up there okay but it's
it's basically all of this so it's so
that's like all of the you know like
Soho Tribeca I think it's even the Upper
East Side yeah every side so these are
sort of the more expensive places you
can see there's some yellow out here
this must be Williamsburg or Brooklyn
yeah somewhere Carole Garton so just to
get an idea right so now we know this so
we go to the next next slide okay so the
next thing you're looking at you're
saying okay well that's great I know
what how much something costs but
absolutes really do nothing for me so
let me let me understand this in a
different way I get this rent amount so
let me see if I can do a median price to
rent ratio and what that really you can
interpret that is if I bought a house
and put it on the market today for rent
how long would that take me to pay it
off okay so basically I would expect
that the payoff would be faster for less
expensive homes presumably so I look at
this again but the median the median
rate here again is pretty high so it's
even here it's still it's still pretty
consistent in terms of results there a
couple of neighborhoods that are
changing in direction where the median
rent to medium price to rent ratio is a
little different so I say okay well let
me see some more information so the
second the other thing that the MLS data
also gives you is the days to market so
that's really interesting so how long
does it take to sell a place and I would
expect that again in a more expensive
place or a bigger place would be harder
to sell right so again if you look at
this which is crazy which is what tells
you how much demand there in the new
york is that it's actually harder to
sell things in the outer boroughs and
it's much easier to sell things inside
right so in Manhattan itself this whole
area that was yellow before that was
because it was so expensive apparently
does not fit on the market very long so
that's very interesting okay
so next up we have the median price to
rent ratio over the days and market so I
don't know if any of you are familiar
with like doing cash flow analysis and
doing asset turnovers and balance sheets
so essentially you're trying to measure
how fast you can turnover and how
efficient your company is at earning
over assets so this is like a similar
ratio to say okay well how fast can can
someone actually move this
you know based on how fast can be paid
back and how many days does it take to
sell on it so kind of efficiency so
again so oh okay oh yeah perfect so this
kind of shows you again so on the on the
left hand side you have the the median
days to market and you have the median
price to rent ratio and it kind of again
oh man these are like this has been very
difficult I don't know if all of you
have tried using plotly at all in
markdown documents and arrogant I've
been having a lot of trouble with it so
anyway but a lot of these labels match
up to what you would expect to be sort
of the expensive neighborhoods I think
out here was like Tribeca and other so
just as an idea this was an interesting
measure and it was interesting that it
all clustered on one side to say that
you know most things are actually
probably pretty good so and then the
other thing that comes up is when you
look at a neighborhood as we talked
about earlier was to say okay well there
must be a spread right like every every
apartment in that neighborhood can't be
the same price can't be just expensive
the other thing I didn't do in this was
I didn't break this down by bedroom type
so that was something I was trying to do
but it I think I have to do some more
merging to get that information and
there's oh yeah in terms of the dirty
data there was quite a bit of dirty data
in in actually the MLS because they have
provided locations but none of the
neighborhood's actually matched so I had
to lay down a map of New York City in
order to make sure it mapped to the
right neighborhood because the latitude
longitude was all off so so going back
to this the spread of the prices per
neighborhood so again it's it's
interesting because again a lot of them
are concentrated in like the lower
Millions
but you see like something like Tribeca
is like oh there's like a 10 million
dollar apartment there I was really
hoping that would go the other direction
that there'd be like things in the lower
end and I'm hoping to obviously expand
this analysis outside New York City
where things are a little bit more
affordable so but it was good to try and
have fun with it
okay so as I promised since this is
slightly about finance as well it has to
include finance I figured we could make
a cash flow statement because that's
really the goal of this analysis is to
say well how can you actually project
this information out once you have built
these built B's statistics how can you
tell somebody
how where to invest so we just so here
I'm just building a very simple model
I'm taking the annualized income which
they gave us the MLS gives us monthly
estimates so I'm just you know
annualizing that then I'm doing expenses
which is up again the MLS data gives me
the the HOA and I'm using the fin calc
package to actually calculate the
mortgage payments so that would be my
expense portion and I'll show you I
think at the bottom I've laid out the
formula and how to calculate mortgage
payment so you know you're taking I
assume it's a 5% rate 30-year regular
standard mortgage and then so that gives
you just a basic idea of what profit
looks like which is kind of cool because
most of the time when you're looking at
houses I don't know if any of you have
gone shopping houses it's not that easy
to figure out what something's worth and
there are not that many data sources
that aggregate things in a way that's
actually coherent or cohesive so that's
so this is I wish I could really use
this before so I decided you know since
we have a lot of our ladies that have
recently moved to Brooklyn I think we
were talking about this a couple days
ago so I thought I would just show you
the top like you know the highest profit
you can make in Williamsburg these days
it doesn't seem to be a whole lot as you
can see but there is some positive
happening there so there are so it was
interesting that there are some
neighborhoods where you kind of expect
that positive cash flow versus others so
I I imagine that eventually I would
probably turn this one into an app once
I like clean everything up and so I hope
that all of you can try it out give
feedback on it okay so as I said next
steps would be to include much more much
more information in terms of extended
area so even outside New York City
outside the borough is obviously and
probably I would want to extend my
analysis to other areas like
Pennsylvania and New Jersey etc and so
the other and the other things I'd like
to do is to maybe build some more
signals so I was really interested in
building incorporating more retail sets
like I think I was reading about how
they were incorporating like Dunkin
Donuts and Starbucks into that so I
wonder how much of a predictor that is
of areas and you know their prices so if
anyone's done that work I'd love to talk
about it and again extend this all over
the US okay so why am I doing this
other than wanting to buy an apartment
these are my two co-workers that love
love love real estate data so they've
got me hooked and it gave me a chance to
really learn something different from my
day job and I got them got to learn
super cool packages like like leaflet
which you'll actually hear about Angela
she's going to talk about it later on
today I think and that's pretty much it
thank you
[Applause]